bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24
nous sommes à abidjan à l'assemblée
nationale et mon invité son président
adama bictogo bienvenus bonsoir
le 7 juin vous avez été élu à la tête de
cette assemblée nationale de façon
j'allais dire presque inhabituelle parce
que avec le soutien de l'opposition
on sait que c'est rarement le cas dans
la politique ivoirienne que s'est il
passé
merci je voudrais profiter donc de
l'opportunité que vous m'offrez tout
d'abord exprimer toute ma gratitude et
reconnaissance au président alassane
ouattara qui m'a d'abord désigné comme
candidat du rhdp et qui m'a donc permis
d'être candidat à l'élection de la
présidence de l'assemblée
j'oserais prolonger ses remerciements au
président henri konan-bédié opposant
laurent gbagbo qui ont été donc les
mandants des différents groupes
parlementaires pdci et pépé assis et
aussi au président mabri toikeuse ce que
je voudrais dire de ce qui est arrivé
c'est d'abord le contexte nous sommes
dans un contexte apaisé nous sortons
d'un dialogue politique où les
différents partis ont su donc
osé
les fondamentaux la convergence qui doit
nous amener à la paix alors au
renforcement de la cohésion sociale mais
il faut aussi ajouter que pendant un an
d'intérim nous avons su créé la famille
parlementaire nous avons sur développer
des relations avec pour objectif de
pouvoir aller au delà des chapelles
politiques de revenir vraiment un esprit
fraternel de maintenir le débat le débat
contradictoire mais que cela se fasse
dans un climat apaisé dans un
environnement apaisé c'est ce que nous
avons fait c'est vrai que je me suis
présenté comme le candidat du consensus
mais il faut donc ajouter que je suis
certainement la conséquence des
différentes tractations qui ont lieu
depuis quelques mois des différentes
postures et position qui ceux qui ont
évolué depuis quelques mois et
d'ailleurs on le voit tout dernièrement
charles blé goudé a reçu son passeport
on peut noter que depuis le re de son
retour le président gbagbo
évoluent librement à travers la côte
d'ivoire y va de la vie voyage revient
le président bédié entretient de bonnes
relations avec le président alassane
ouattara donc je considère que c'est
tout un ensemble
d'éléments qui ont permis donc à
l'opposition
d'être rassurés et de
ne pouvoir réellement porté au
mon élection
à la présidence de l'assemblée nationale
donc ce que vous dites quand même en
effet c'est que ce n'est pas un hasard
c'est pas juste un accident c'est le
fruit de tractations donc on imagine au
plus haut niveau entre alassane ouattara
laurent gbagbo et henri konan-bédié
c'est eux qui ont donné le feu vert ce
vote à l'unanimité je veux dire il ya
une deux composantes il y à ce que les
représentants de ses mandants à
l'assemblée ce que nous avons su créé
comme ambiance
à travers donc nous relations mais ce
qu'il faut noter c'est que les membres
dans le présent de la savoie talent
présent les cons à bédié président
laurent gbagbo sans qu'il y ait des
tractions des tractations cibler non ce
que je veux dire ils ont une relation
apaisée et que certainement ses
relations apaisées entre nos mandants
ont aussi favorisé donc les relations
que nous avons obtenus en plus tenons
notre assemblée nationale regorge de
l'ensemble de tous les acteurs
politiques plaies de notre pays et ceci
est important parce que le secrétaire
exécutif en chef du pdc en la personne
de maurice guikahué a débuté moi-même
secrétaire exécutive du rhdp je siège à
l'assemblée le président exécutif du pp
à séoul à hubert est à l'assemblée mabri
toikeuse est à l'assemblée pour l'infime
dessin et à l'assemblée mais ce sont ces
acteurs là qu'ils ont décidé ensemble de
dire nous avons tous connu en côte
d'ivoire la rébellion les violences les
marches mais à la fin nous avons terminé
par le dialogue
dorénavant pourquoi ne pas commencer par
le dialogue pour aboutir au renforcement
de la cohésion sociale
dans le but de renforcer la construction
de notre nation alors cela pose la
question on parle depuis quelques
semaines d'une possible rencontre
justement à trois entre alassane
ouattara henri konan bédié et laurent
gbagbo est ce que ça va se faire et si
oui quand je voudrais dire que déjà
lors du dialogue politique
nous l'avons souhaité les mêmes acteurs
qui sont dialogue politique sont les
mêmes qui sont à l'assemblée nous
l'avons souhaité et nous pensons avoir
eu des échos favorables
donc nous attendons de voir
et d'ailleurs c'est une volonté affichée
par le président le plus je me souviens
encore qu'au moins de jus et dernier en
mille 2021 lorsqu'il recevait le
président laurent gbagbo il avait donc
évoqué la possibilité de la rencontre
avec le président bédié présent leur a
fait quasiment un an willy que mai mais
ceci étant il n'y a pas eu de rupture
c'est la rupture ils se parlent je donne
pour exemple nous étions à daoukro la
semaine dernière pour présenter nos
condoléances au président henri konan
bédié et nous a été indiquée de de
transmettre au président alassane
ouattara
tous leurs remerciements et gratitude
aux son apport
et sa présence continue aux côtés du
présent les konan bédié lors du décès de
son frère donc c'est dire qu'il y a une
relation qui entretenue entre les
différents chefs maintenant le
calendrier politique relève de leurs
différents agenda ceci étant nous
restons convaincus que
le président alassane ouattara
car affiché sa volonté donc de
rassembler les ivoiriens autour de
l'idéal de paix ou une stabilité d'une
côte d'ivoire forte
naturellement
respectera ce que lui-même il a indiqué
en 2021 lorsqu'il recevait le président
laurent gbagbo c'est une question
d'agenda c'est une question d'agenda
alors il ya eu un projet de loi qui est
à l'assemblée nationale ici qui pourrait
peut-être les diviser il est présenté
par un député indépendant antoine assalé
tiémoko depuis le mois d'avril qui
propose de ré établir la limite d'âge
pour se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle à 75 ans ce qui de facto
éliminerait les trois géants de la
politique ivoirienne convient d'évoquer
on sait qu'alassane ouattara y est
plutôt favorable
laurent gbagbo est totalement contre où
en est ce projet de loi d'abord c'est un
projet de loi parce que
il a introduit il a initié donc c'est
une proposition qui man band députés
nous n'avons pas encore établi la
recevabilité donc de cette demande donc
on ne peut pas parler de projet de loi
ceci étant de mon point de vue et c'est
un point de vue personnel je considère
que la démocratie doit pouvoir
s'exprimer sans qu'on soit obligé
d'élaborer une constitution
personnalisés je nous avons une
constitution qui permet à tout ivoirien
de 35 ans sans limite d'âge pour être
candidat si les partis politiques
considèrent que lé président de leur
parti en l'état nonobstant lâches qu'ils
ont sont capables de se présenter comme
candidat je considère que notre
constitution si la constitution le
permet il faut donc s'en tenir à la
constitution dont vous êtes défavorable
à rétablir la limite d'âge non je vous
dis restons coller à la constitution
couleurs il n'y a pas eu de loin
parlant de limite d'âge donc moi je
reste collé à la constitution et c'est
la constitution qui régit qui permet
donc au code électoral de
d'établi donc la possibilité des
candidatures vous le connaissez bien est
ce que vous n'avez pas quand même le
sentiment qu'il aimerait bien réussir sa
sortie entre guillemets
qu'est ce que vous appelez le succès de
sa sortie ce qu'il avait voulu faire la
dernière fois à savoir dire voilà je ne
représente pas et je laisse la place aux
jeunes oui non mais est ce que la
qualité de diriger est liée à l'âge ou à
la compétence ou à la vision ma part je
considère que le président alassane
ouattara
lorsque nous échangeons avec lui on note
que l'âge n'a pas impacté sa vision pour
la côte d'ivoire on note que l'âge n'a
pas entamé sa volonté d'offrir le
bonheur au peuple de côte d'ivoire donc
je ne veux pas inscrire l'âge comme
étant un handicap à la capacité du
président alassane ouattara a continué
de donner le bonheur aux ivoiriens adama
bictogo merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
nos questions depuis l'assemblée
nationale ici à abidjan côte d'ivoire
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cet entretien
sur france 24
[Musique]